[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من واحه الاستقرار والديمقراطيه
في غرب افريقيا السنغال تحديدا الى القاره
التي تحيا تيها طويلا ولا نهائيا على ما
يبدو وبعد عقود من محاولات الاستقرار
والنهضه والتخلص من ارث الاستعمار
الاوروبي البشع الذي تاجر حتى بالبشر
والثروات واستغلها اسوا استغلال الى
التعثر في وحل الانقلابات والتدخلات
الخارجيه التي لا ترى في القاره سوى فرصه
استثماريه كبرى لا يجب تفويتها نطل الليله
من العاصمه دكار مع رئيس احدى دول الاكواس
المجموعه الاقتصاديه التي ابتليت باربع
عضويات مجمده من خمسه عشره دوله هي مجموع
دول المنظمه ومع الرئيس مكه سال الذي تنظر
بلاده بعين القلق لما يجري في مالي
والنيجر وغينيا وبوركينا فاسو اذ ينظر
الرجل بعين الخوف والوجل لما يجري في
المحيط مع اماله الكبرى باستمرار النهضه
في بلاده والتي يدرك تماما ان لا يمكن ان
تستمر دون استقرار ونهضه الدول المحيطه
بها اتحدث الليله عن بلاد الفرص الفرص
المستثمره على نحو ما والضائعه على نحو
اخر في محاوله لفهم واقعي ومستقبل القاره
الافريقيه الرئيس السنغالي ماكيسال ضيف
المقابله هذه الحلقه والحلقه التي تليها
ابحث معه اليوم الشؤون الافريقيه واتناول
في الحلقه القادمه الديمقراطيه والنهضه
والتنميه الاستثنائيه في السنغال في واحده
من التجارب اللافته والنادره في القاره
الافريقيه فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
من هنا من ذكار عاصمه السنغال واحه
الاستقرار الاستثنائيه في غرب افريقيا مع
ضيفنا الرئيس السنغالي ماركسال مرحبا بك
السيد الرئيس سعداء جدا بهذه الفرصه التي
تمنحنا اياها في المقابله في حلقتين
نتناول فيهما
اوضاع افريقيا بشكل عام والسنغال على وجه
الخصوص شكرا جزيلا لك ميرسي بوكو بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
في هذا البرنامج للحديث عن افريقيا وعن
السنغال ايضا سعيد بلقائكم نحن دائما
نعتقد منذ طفولتنا انها ثمه علاقه
استثنائيه وخاصه تربط السنغال بالعالم
العربي بشكل خاص من ايام الرئيس عبد
الضيوفه بعد ذلك وقبل ذلك ايضا ربما هذه
مناسبه جيده للحديث عن كل هذه الامور وعن
العلاقات ايضا سواء مع العالم العربي
والعلاقات بشكل عام هل تشعرون بخصوصيه ما
في العلاقات مع العالم العربي
نعم هي علاقات متميزه وعريقه تعود الى ما
قبل استقلال السنغال بكثير اولا نحن ابناء
دين واحد وهو الاسلام وكما تعلمون دخل
الاسلام الى السنغال منذ 1200 عام حيث وصل
الى هذا الجزء من افريقيا منذ عشره او 11
قرن مباشره بعد المغرب العربي وموريتانيا
دخل السنغال كبوابه الى افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء ومنذ ذلك الحين اصبحت علاقاتنا
قديمه دينيه وتجاريه وهذا هو ما استمر حتى
استقلال بلادنا
ورئيسنا الاول وعلى الرغم من كونه غير
مسلم فانه بنى علاقات جيده مع ملوك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه انذاك ومع
القاده مختلف الدول العربيه
استمرت هذه العلاقات في عهد الرئيسين عبد
الضيوف وعبد الله واد كما تستمر معي شخصيا
اللغه العربيه حاضره بشكل جيد في السنغال
اللغه العربيه حاضره جدا في البيوت
الدينيه لمشايخ الطرق الصوفيه وفي المدارس
القرانيه نحن لدينا نظام التعليم مزدوج
النظام الغربي التقليدي من خلال المدارس
الفرنسيه
ونظام التعليم العربي من خلال المدارس
القرانيه
ولدينا نسبه كبيره من السنغاليين الذين
تلقوا تعليمهم باللغه العربيه
ولهذا السبب قمت ليس فقط باعتماد الشهاده
الثانويه باللغه العربيه رسميا فحسب بل
قمت بمنح الذين تلقوا تعليمهم باللغه
العربيه امكانيه الحصول على مؤهلات في
مجال الدبلوم
ليصبحوا مستشارين في وزاره الخارجيه وفي
القنصليات كما اننا نوظفهم بوتيره متناميه
في الوظائف العموميه المحليه سواء كانوا
مدرسين او اطباء او من الفئات الاخرى
سيدرا مخصصه للحلقه للنقاش في وضع افريقيا
وانتم رئيس لواحد من البلدان الرئيسيه
وايضا انتم رئيس الدوله عضو في الاكواس
مجموعه المجموعه الاقتصاديه لغرب افريقيا
15 دوله اربع دول منها مجمده عضيتها بسبب
انقلابات العسكريه هل يبدو ان حاله
الاستقرار السياسيه في افريقيا بدات
تتراجع بشكل كبير مؤخرا النيجر وما قبلها
تعرفون توجد لدينا في غرب افريقيا منظمه
اقليميه على غرار المناطق الافريقيه
الاخرى فالقاره مقسمه الى مجموعات
اقتصاديه اقليميه في الجزء الغربي هناك
المجموعه الاقتصاديه للدول غرب افريقيا
اكواس وفي الشرق مجموعه شرق افريقيا وفي
الجنوب توجد المجموعه الانمائيه للجنوب
الافريقي وفي منطقه الوسط الافريقيه لديهم
المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول وسط افريقيا
وكذلك الاتحاد المغاربي في شمال افريقيا
هكذا تتكون القاره وبما ان القاره شاسعه
جدا فان كل مجموعه تعنى بمسائل التنظيم
فيها والتكامل والقضايا السياسيه
والديمقراطيه الاخرى مثل حريه التنقل
الاشخاص والممتلكات والدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان
ومنذ امد بعيد تتحرك اقواس من اجل وضع حد
لظاهره الانقلابات التي شهدتها القاره
غداه استقلالها ففي السنوات الاولى من
الاستقلال كان الجيش هو الذي يتولى السلطه
فكان يطيح بالرئيس لادنى سبب ومن ثم كان
من الضروري ان يعمل رؤساء الدول في تلك
الاونه على وضع حد للانقلابات وبفضل ذلك
حدثت موجه من التحول الديمقراطي على مدار
20 او 30 عاما وفي الاونه الاخيره طرات
الازمه المرتبطه بالتهديد الارهابي وكانت
بلدان الساحل الكبرى اولى ضحاياها كما بات
من الواضح ان المشكلات الامنيه التي وقعت
في مالي بالاضافه الى الازمه الاقتصاديه
سهلت استيلاء الجيش على السلطه فيها
وحاولت اقواس في بادي الامر التفخم الوضع
ودعمت العمليه الانتقاليه
ولاحقا وقعت انقلابات في غيني وفي بوركينا
فاسو ثم في النيجر ومؤخرا في الغابون لقد
اصبح الامر هواء لكن قناعتي هي ان
الانقلاب ليس حلا لان الجيوشا غير مدربه
على اداره الدول ولكن للدفاع عن البلاد
والدفاع عن سيادتها وعن سلامه اراضها ولكل
عمله ووظيفته وهذه الوظيفه نبيله وجديره
بالثناء لكنهم غير مدربين على اداره الدول
وبناء على ذلك فاللجوء الى الانقلاب ليس
حلا للمشكلات التي تواجهها بلداننا بل على
العكس يجب علينا ان نسعى الى خلق التازر
بحيث تعمل جميع القوى الحيويه على الصعيد
الوطني للدفاع عن سلامه هذه البلدان
المهدده ومن هذا المنظور فمعركتنا واحده
لا ينبغي ترك اي دوله سواء مالي او النيجر
او بوركينا فاسو تواجه الارهابيين بمفردها
بل يتعين علينا اولا وقبل كل شيء والامم
المتحده في المقدمه من خلال مجلس الامن ان
نقوم بحشد كافه الموارد لمكافحه الارهاب
ولا يمكننا ان نترك المساله لدوله واحده
لتتعامل معها فهذا ليس عدلا وليس من
الانصاف
كما لا ينبغي للعسكريين ان يحملوا السلاح
للاستيلاء على السلطه بسبب خلاف بسيط انا
وعارض سياسه الانقلاب ويجب وضع حد لها في
بدايه انقلاب في النيجر تحدثتم انتم وساحل
العاج ونيجيريا عن تدخل عسكري يبدو ان هذا
الامر تراجع ايضا بعد اعتراض بوركينا فاسو
ومالي ونشر طائرات والحديث عن مواجهه في
حاله تدخل عسكري في النيجر هل ما زالت
امكانيه التداخل العسكري وارده هناك
نعم بالطبع هذا هو الموقف الاخير لاكواس
وبالتالي هذا هو الموقف الوحيد الساري
المفعول ما لم تتراجع عنه لكن علينا ان
نتفاهم بهذا الشان لم تقل اكواس انها
ستستخدم القوه على الفور لاجبار الجيش على
التنازل هذا هو الاجراء الاخير وفي حال
فشلت جميع المساعد الدبلوماسيه الجاريه
فليس من المستبعد اللجوء الى هذا الخيار
الذي استخدمته الجماعه مرارا في السابق
لقد فعلنا ذلك مؤخرا في عام 2017 في حاله
غامبيا وقبلها في بلدان اخرى في غينيا
بيساو وسيراليون وفي ليبيريا اذن ليس
جديدا ان تدافع ايكواس عن استقرار
المؤسسات او تدافع عن الديمقراطيه في بلد
ما لاستعاده النظام ومساعده السكان على
الخروج من المازق وفيما يتعلق بالنيجر
هناك
بشان هذا الموضوع وكنت شخصيا اتمنى ان
يستمع الجيش الى صوت العقل ويتعاون مع
اقواس من اجل التوصل الى حل والحل هو ان
يتنحو عن السلطه وعندئذ لم نحتاج الى تدخل
عسكري لماذا لا يحدث كما حدث في 2017 تدخل
عسكري وحسم الامر لماذا ترددتم في مساله
التدخل عسكري في في النيجر كما حدث في
غامبيا المره الماضيه
مره اخرى لم نتردد كما تعلمون يجب التعامل
مع كل حاله على حده ليست النيجر والنيجر
ليست نيجيريا كل موقف وكل سياق وكل فتره
تتطلب تقييما خاصا غامبيا مجاوره للسنغال
ولذلك تعاملت السنغال مع حالتها وفيما
يتعلق بالنيجر هناك دول متاخمه لها اعتقد
انه يجب ان تكون تلك الدول في الطليعه ثم
بعد ذلك يمكن لجميع البلدان الاخرى التي
تتفق معها في الرؤى بما فيها السنغال ان
تنضم اليها لتقديم الدعم في اطار تدخل
مسلح اذا كان هذا هو الخيار الامثل ولكنهم
لا يحبذون الحديث عن الخيار المسلح واعتقد
ان علينا الاستمرار في المساعي ولكن يجب
على الجيش ايضا ان يستمع الى المنطق
السليم فلا يمكننا القبول باستمرار احتجاز
الرئيس المنتخب ديمقراطيا من قبل الاشخاص
الذين يفترض منهم ان يحرسوه انه شيء يصدم
الض مير يجب ان يتفاوض مع ايكواس حول شروط
وضع حد لهذا الانقلاب في الغابون اختلف
الامر
في الجابون اختلف الامر بعدها بشهر يعني
اصبح تفسير وتقدير الامر مختلف ليست
مبدئيه
لا بالعكس انه مبدا ولكن لكل انقلاب شكله
الخاص وما حدث في الغابون له نفس النتيجه
يعني انه كانت هناك عمليه انتخابيه جاريه
ولكن الجيش اعتبر ان الامر كان سيجر
البلاد نحو وضع صعب فقرروا انهاء حكم
الرئيس بانجو وحبسوه في المنزل قبل ان
يطلقوا سراحه لاحقا ولم يعد اليوم سجينا
ويبقى الان مبدا رفض اي شكل من اشكال
الاستهلاء غير القانوني وغير الدستور على
السلطه هذا هو المبدا ولكن كل موقف يتطلب
تعاملا خاصا به حسب الحاله ولكن من حيث
المبدا ندين جميع الانقلابات ومره اخرى
هناك منظمه اخرى معنيه بالمنطقه التي تقع
فيها الجابون غير ايكواس وهي المجموعه
الاقتصاديه للدول افريقيا الوسطى وهي في
الخطوط الاماميه وهناك ايضا الاتحاد
الافريقي الذي رفضه واستنكاره لما حدث في
الجابون
سيد الرئيس هل يبدو اننا امام عوده
لانقلابات وحاله عدم الاستقرار السياسي في
افريقيا يعني لدينا الانقلاب في النيجر
الغابون غامبيا لدينا محاولتين في بوركينا
فاسو في 2022 محاولات فاشله في غينيا
وغامبيا وهناك ست محاولات ايضا في عام 21
نجحت اربع منها
الاستقرار مرتبط بالنهضه والتنميه كانه
صار في رده في موضوع الاستقرار السياسي في
ظل عدم وجود حسم الاتحاد الافريقي طبعا
اذا رجعنا وراء ايضا السودان لدينا حاله
مصر قبل ذلك يبدو انه الاتحاد الافريقي
ليس حاسما ولا جازما في مساله رفض
الانقلابات
لا لا تضحكني بتعليقك هذا الاتحاد
الافريقي مظلوم لسوء الحظ بالنسبه له هو
لافريقيا فان جميع الصراعات في القاره تتم
برعايه خارجيه انها صراعات ذات تداعيات
خارجيه ولها تمويل خارجي وهذا ما يقلل من
تاثير الاتحاد الافريقي خاصه انه اذا كان
الامر يتعلق باتخاذ اجراء صارم حيث يجب
التوجه الى مجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده وفي كثير من الاحيان يتم استخدام
حق النقض الامر الذي يؤدي في نهايه المطاف
الى تجميد قرارات متخذه كان يفترض ان
تساعد في ايجاد حل لو نفذت لا نخفل ايضا
ايادي بعض القوى وبالتالي ستفهمون لماذا
يعتقد الناس ان اطراف الصراع المختلفه
سواء في السودان او في ليبيا او في جميع
البلدان التي تشهد انقلابات يجب ان يكونوا
مدعومين من قبل
ولهذا السبب فان الاتحاد الافريقيه او
ايكواس الذين كان فعالين للغايه في حل
المشكلات سابقا يرى تحيدهما بفعل هذا
التدخل الخارجي في القاره الافريقيه وهذا
هو الواقع المرير الذي ناسف له
من هي الايادي الخارجيه التي تعبث
باستقرار افريقيا وتدعم الانقلاباتنا
انقلابات في النيجر في الغابون في غامبيا
في كل الدول
الايادي الخارجيه هي جميع القوى التي
تتحرك عندما يكون هناك صراع في اتجاه او
اخر وتدعم هذا الطرف او ذاك او من يسلح
هذا او ذاك ومن يعرقل هذا القرار او ذاك
في مجلس الامن هذه هي الحياه اليوميه في
القاره وهذا ما يعني عموما ان الازمات
التي كان من الممكن حلها بسهوله في يوم من
الايام اصبحت غير قابله للحل انظروا الى
ما يحدث في السودان اليوم وسط لا مبالاه
عامه وان حاول الاتحاد الافريقي فما هي
قدراته الحقيقيه على حمل الطرفين على ضبط
النفس والاحتكام الى العقل ووقف اطلاق
النار ومناقشه المشكلات الحقيقيه التي من
شانها الحفاظ على الارواح التي تزهق يوميا
هذا هو الواقع والوضع في ليبيا اسوا وهناك
صراعات اخرى في القاره تخضع لتاثيرات
خارجيه الامر الذي يجعل من حل الازمات
اصعب مما كان في السابق
[موسيقى]
ثروات طبيعيه هائله وامكانات اقتصاديه
ضخمه جعلت القاره السمراء بؤره اهتمام
عالمي وميدان تنافس دولي محموم كانت فرنسا
اول المتنبهين الى اهميه افريقيا في العصر
الحديث فسعت الى بسط هيمنتها عليها منذ
بدايات القرن السابع عشر وشكلت السنغال
بوابه التمدد الفرنسي في انحاء القاره حين
عمد الفرنسيون الى انشاء اول مراكزهم
التجاريه عبر استغلال السكان المحليين
واليوم تعد افريقيا المزود الرئيس لباريس
بالطاقه واليورانيوم والمعادن اذ تحكم
فرنسا قبضتها على مناجم الذهب وحقول النفط
في عدد لا يستهان به من بلدان القاره
الموسومه بالفقر والتخلف في مفارقه مع ما
تتمتع به من امكانات اما امريكا فاتجهت
نحو تبني مقاربه جيوس استراتيجيه وامنيه
جديده في مناطق متفرقه على راسها افريقيا
وذلك ضمن استراتيجيتها الرام لتعزيز
هيمنتها العالميه لكن في حين تضع فرنسا
عينها على خيرات القاره ترمي الولايات
المتحده الى احتواء الصين التي وسعت
حضورها بالقاره بطريقه غير مسبوقه ولا
سيما في العقدين الاخيرين فقد خصصت بكين
استثمارات ضخمه في مشاريع البنيه التحتيه
الافريقيه وبلغ حجم التجاره الصينيه مع
افريقيا اكثر من 200 مليار دولار مقابل
نحو 90 مليارا فقط مع الولايات المتحده
روسيا بدورها لم تغب عن مشهد التنافس
المتصاعد فهي ترغب بتعزيز مكانتها داخل
افريقيا بهدف ايجاد اسواق اقتصاديه بديله
تحررها من قيود العقوبات الغربيه وعبر
مخلب مجموعه فاغنر ترسخ موسكو مصالحها
الامنيه والعسكريه داخل القاره
[موسيقى]
هناك كاتب صحفي في موقع
الشهير يقول ان التمرد في النيجر هو رقم
11 الذي يقوده ضباط عسكريون تلقوا تدريبا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع تعليقك
سيدي الرئيس
لا اعرف ما اذا كانوا قد تلقوا تدريبهم في
الولايات المتحده ولكن بغض النظر عن مكان
تدريبهم عندما ينفذ الجندي انقلابا فهو
انقلابي تلقى بعض هؤلاء الانقلابيين
تدريبهم في السنغال وانتم تدركون جيدا انه
لم يحدث في السنغال اي انقلاب على الاطلاق
ففي النيجر الذي استولى على السلطه تلقى
تدريبه هنا في السنغال ونحن في مدارس
الضباط لا نعلم الناس كيفيه تنفيذ
انقلابات وعليه فان الدول التي تدربهم لا
تتحمل بالضروره اللوم ولا اعتقد ان الدول
من خلال تدريب الضباط تع للقيام
بالانقلابات عندما يعودون الى بلدانهم
طبعا هو الاشاره هنا الى عمق الامر الى
وجود صراع على النفوذ داخل افريقيا النفوذ
التقليدي والتاريخي كان لفرنسا الان يراد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تحتل موقعا
اكثر تاثيرا في في دول الافريقيه
لا ارى اي مشكله بين الولايات المتحده
وفرنسا كان لفرنسا تاثير قديم في افريقيا
في الجزء الذي نسميه بافريق الناطقه
بالفرنسيه ولكن هناك افريقيا الناطقه
بالانجليزيه وكان للانجليز ايضا تاثيرهم
فيها هناك ايضا افريقيا ناطقه بالبرتغاليه
وافريقيا الناطقه بالاسبانيه وكان لكل من
هذه القوى الاستعماريه مستعمراتها السابقه
ومنذ الاستقلال اراد البعض الحفاظ على
العلاقات والنفوذ نفسهما وهذه العلاقات
تتغير لان باتت مستقله منذ 62 عاما ومن
الواضحه انها تنوعت في البحث عن شركاء
اخرين لانها تعيش عصر العولمه ولا يمكنها
ان تختصر على هذه العلاقات الاستعماريه
القديمه ولذلك فمن الطبيعي ان يتغير
التاثير الذي كان تتمتع به فرنسا او
المملكه المتحده او القوه القديمه او
البرتغال على المستعمرات السابقه وهذا
التاثير ينحسر وهذا شيء طبيعي بفعل
التاريخ الذي يجري ولا يمنع ذلك من بناء
علاقات تعاون قائمه على روح الشراكه
المربحه للجانبين وهذا ما نحاول تعزيزه مع
شركائنا السابقين مثل الفرنسيين ساتحدث عن
عن هذا الامر سؤال يعني سؤال بفرضيتنا
اولا
لماذا تبدو السنغال بعيده عن حاله
الاضطراب والانقلابات وهل هي فعلا بعيده
يعني اليوم
بعيده عن فكره او احتماليه انقلابات
عسكريه انهيار الاستقرار السياسي فيها
لا اعتقد ذلك فكما تعلمون لكل دوله واقعها
التاريخي والسنغال هي اولا وقبل كل شيء
ديمقراطيه قديمه وتاريخنا الديمقراطي ليس
وليد اليوم اود ان اذكركم اننا بدانا نجري
انتخابات هنا في هذا البلد منذ عام
1860 بان الاستعمار الفرنسي في ذلك الوقت
وفي عام
1776 اي 13 عاما قبل الثوره الفرنسيه حدثت
ثوره ثيوقراطيه في منطقه فوتا شماليه
السنغال حيث كان الاسلام هو القوه
السياسيه التي حلت محل المماليك
التقليديين ومنذ ذلك الحين لم نكف عن
تحقيق التطور في مسيرنا الديمقراطي وفي
عام 1914
السنغالي هنا وتغلب على الفرنسيين في
انتخابات تشريعيه هذا الشخص هو بليز ديانه
الذي يحمل مطارنا الدولي اسمه وبالتالي
فهي عمليه ديمقراطيه قديمه جدا وخلال هذه
الحقبه الاستعماريه كانت هناك كتيبه خاصه
من الجيش الاستعماري سميت بكتابه الرومات
السنغاليين وهكذا تدرب جيشنا منذ الحقبه
الاستعماريه ومنذ الحروب المختلفه التي
شارك فيها ومنها الحرب الهند الصينيه
وقبلها الحربان العالميتان الاولى
والثانيه وحرب الجزائر وغيرها من الحروب
بهذه الظروف نشا الجيش السنغالي عام 1960
عند الاستقلال يفهم الجندي هنا جيدا انه
يخضع لسلطه المدني وهذه هي القاعده لدينا
وعلى هذا يجري تدريبهم وهم فخورون بالخدمه
العسكريه باسم الجمهوريه ووظيفتهم ليست
تنفيذ ان ضد الرؤساء المدنيين المنتخبين
لا اعتقد ان هذا يمكن ان يكون موجودا في
اذهان الجنود السنغاليين رغم التاثيرات
السلبيه التي يحاول البعض القيام بها عبر
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي لان الناس ينسون
ان لكل دوله تاريخها الخاص والسنغال ليست
من هذا النوع وهذا ربما هو حظنا ويمكن
تفسير الاستقرار الذي نتمتع به ايضا بهذه
الحريه وهذه الديمقراطيه القديمه التي
ليست وليده البارحه اللعبه السياسيه
مفتوحه والمؤسسات تعمل والجيش يؤدي دوره
كما هو مطلوب وهو الدفاع عن الاراضي
الوطنيه والمساهمه في بناء مفهوم الجيش
والامه والعيش يقوم بدوره بشكل جيد للغايه
الاتحاد الافريقي الان يا مؤخرا تم ضمه
لمجموعه العشرين وهذا ايضا بجهود انت
ساهمت فيها كثيرا حاله عدم الاستقرار
والانقلابات والتدهور السياسي تؤثر على
مكانه افريقيا بشكل كبير عام 2024 ايضا
سيد الرئيس في استحقاقات كبيره اكثر من 20
انتخابات مقرره في بلدان افريقيا منها
السنغال وهناك ايضا قروض واقساط مقرره
يعني يحين دفعها في عام 2024 كلها تحديات
تواجه افريقيا فنحن من ناحيه نتحدث عن
افريقيا قويه ناهضه اقتصاد اكبر ومن ناحيه
اخرى كانه هناك قلق على حاله الاستقرار
والنمو الذي يجري في افريقيا
علينا ان نكون منصفين معي افريقيا افريقيا
تتكون من 54 دوله ويبلغ عدد سكانها مليارا
و300 مليون نسمه وهناك اربع او خمس دول
تعاني من مشكلات واذا اعتبرنا بالمتوسط
لنعرف هل افريقيا في وضع جيد ام لا فليس
لان هناك اربعه او خمسه انقلابات فقط يجب
ان نعتبر افريقيا باكملها غير مستقره
سيكون هذا بمثابه اصدار حكم غير منصف ولا
يتوافق مع الواقع ماذا عن الخمسين او 49
دوله الاخرى حيث كل شيء يسير على ما يرام
هل نعتبر كل هذا صفرا لا
الانقلابات والصعوبات هما جميع ما نتحدث
عنه لا افريقيا متنوعه حقا تبلغ مساحتها
30 مليون كيلومتر مربع ويبلغ عدد سكانها
مليارا و300 مليون نسمه وهناك اشياء
استثنائيه
يحدث في هذه القاره لذلك افضل ان نركز على
ما ينجح في افريقيا وليس على جوانب الفشل
نعم ندرك ذلك ونحاول تقديم الحلول تدريجيا
ولكن لا يمكننا ان نقبل بان يركز الناس
فقط على المشكلات في كل مره نتحدث فيه عن
افريقيا فهي قاره شابه والدنماركيه تساعد
العالم على مواجهه التحول في الطاقه بسبب
الموارد المعدنيه الاساسيه وندره الاراضي
والمعادن اذا كنا نتحدث عن التحول الى
انماط اخرى من الطاقه سيتعين علينا العثور
على الليثيوم والكوبالت والعثور على كل
هذه المعادن التي يتم انتاجها بشكل رئيسي
في القاره وما يجب القيام به هو مساعده
القاره على تحويل الثرواتها محليا لخلق
قيمه مضافه وخلق فرص عمل لابقاء الافارقه
في القاره ومنحهم افاق مستقبليه واعتقد
اننا اذا نظرنا الى التنميه من هذا
المنظور سنفهم افريقيا مختلف وسنفهم ان
افريقيا يمكنها ان تكون شريكا مفيدا
للعالم اجمع لان كل شخص لديه مكانه هنا
نظرا للانتاج لدينا 60% من الاراضي
الصالحه لزراعه في العالم ولدينا انهار
ولدينا كل ما نحتاجه وما نفتقر اليه هو
التمويل المناسب التمويل الكافي الذي يسمح
بتنميه الاستثمار والتوظيف في القاره ونحن
نناضل من اجل تغيير الحوكمه العالميه ايضا
من اجل تغيير القواعد التي تجعل افريقيا
تعتبر محفوفه بالمخاطر نتحدث دائما في
وسائل الاعلام عن انقلاب او زلزال او
فيضان عندما يتعلق الامر بافريقيا ونبالغ
في ذلك وهذه مشكله وبالتالي يخاف الممولون
لانهم يقولون انها منطقه محفوفه بالمخاطر
وعليه يجب ان نرفع مبالغ بدل المخاطر
واقساط التامين وكل هذا الاستثمارات في
القاره اكثر كلفه هذه هي القضايا التي
نعمل عليها لتغيير المفهوم القائل ان
افريقيا تمثل مشكله بل بالعكس افريقيا هي
حل للعالم ربما افريقيا يجب
سيدي الرئيس افريقيا التي يجب ان تتغير
وليس نظره العالم لها يعني انا شخصيا كنت
في في رواندا قبل
كنت في اثيوبيا قبل رئيس وزراء اثيوبيا
والان في السنغال في دكار وقابل رئيس
باكسال اشاهد بلدان متطوره حقيقه يعني نحن
لا نمنح شهادات لكن ما نشاهده هو شيء مميز
ولكن افريقيا يجب ان تثبت للعالم ايضا
انها هي هي التي تتطور بشكل اكبر بعيدا عن
حاله التوتر والانقلابات في بعض دولها
يجب ان تتغير نظره العالم ازاء افريقيا
لانها ليست دائما نظره ايجابيه ويرجع ذلك
الى اننا نعتبر ان افريقيا هي اولا وقبل
كل شيء قاره شهدت العبوديه وتم بيع البشر
ثلاث او اربع او خمس دول تعاني من صعوبات
ظرفيه فلا يجب ان تنحصر فيها وجهه نظر
الكليه ازاء افريقيا وحكمنا على افريقيا
هذه هي المعركه التي يجب ان نخوضها بشان
تصور الافارقه للقاره وكذلك حول واقع
افريقيا في العالم ايضا ضمن هذه الجولات
في افريقيا وتعرفت على كثير من المثقفين
الافارقه هناك
موجه
مضاده ومناهضه لفرنسا ضد الفرنسا ضد
تاريخها الاستعماري وضد محاولاتها للبقاء
لاعبا رئيسيا على حساب الاقتصاد الافريقي
والثروات الافريقيه انتم حكومتكم مقربه من
فرنسا يبدو انك تخالف وجهه النظر التي
تعادي فرنسا
تعرف انا لست هنا للدفاع عن فرنسا لكنني
اعتقد ايضا انه لا ينبغي لنا ان نعتبر
الافارقه بمثابه خدام المذبح حتى ان البعض
يعتقد ان فرنسا موجوده هناك لتستولي على
مواردنا
هي لا تملك حتى القدره لفعل ذلك حتى لو
ارادت ويوجد احيانا حكم لا يتوافق مع
الواقع الفعلي للامور فالسنغال التي
اتراسها هي السنغال التي قامت بتنويع
شركائها منذ ان اصبحت رئيسها يوجد هنا
صينيون وهم يعملون بكل حريه واتراك
ويعملون بكل حريه فرنسيون والمان
وامريكيون الجميع موجود هنا لماذا تريدون
ان تصدقوا ان السنغال على سبيل المثال
لانها تتكلم الفرنسيه فان فرنسا هي من
يقرر يفعل ما يشاء هذا لا يتوافق مع
الواقع على الاقل في السنغال ولكن هناك
فعلا سياسه تقريع فرنسا اذا جاز التعبير
والتي تتلخص في تدمير صوره فرنسا في
افريقيا وقد تنجح هذه السياسه اذا لم
تتمكن فرنسا من كبح جماح هذه الحمله
المكثفه التي ساعدت شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي في نشرها وفي المقابل يتعين على
الجانب الفرنسيه ايضا ان يتعلم من الاخطاء
والمواقف السابقه حتى يتمكن من تقديم
الصوره الحقيقيه لفرنسا في علاقاتها مع
افريقيا ماذا يجب عليها تحديدا
يجب عليها العمل على تحسين صورتها في
افريقيا ومحاوله فهم افريقيا وما يجري
فيها حاليا فلا يمكننا اليوم استخدام نفس
نظارات القراءه التي كنا نستخدمها قبل
ستين عاما هذا لم يعد ممكننا فلم تعد
افريقيا هي نفسها انا شخصيا ولدت بعد
استقلال السنغال ولا يمكن ان يكون لدينا
نفس المواقف انما يرفضه الافارقه في كثير
من الاحيان هو ما يسمونه بالابويه طريقه
التخاطب كما لو كان الافارقه اطفالا يجب
ان نريهم الطريق الذي يجب ان يتبعوه هذا
ما لا يقبله الناس اعتقد ان هناك وعيا من
الجانب الفرنسي بذلك انا شخصيا تابعت
خطابا لمن للمقرون كان يتحدث فيه الى
سفرائي ويقول لهم لقد ولى ذلك الزمن الذي
كنا فيه وحدنا في القاره وكان الغرب يتمتع
فيه بموقف الهيمنه بشكل عام واليوم
شركاء اخرون من جميع انحاء العالم وفي كل
مكان في افريقيا لذلك يجب على فرنسا
والغربيين بشكل عام ان ياخذوا في الاعتبار
هذا الواقع وهو تعدد الاخطاب والقوى
العامله والموجوده ايضا على الارض
الافريقيه اعتقد ان هذا امر جيد لانه يعكس
منافسه ايجابيه يجب علينا تطوير العلاقات
بطريقه مربحه للجانبين
يقال انه الرئيس مكيسال رئيس السنغال احدث
توازنا في العلاقات الخارجيه عبر ايضا
علاقات مميزه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
تطوير لها لان علاقات قديمه وعلاقات
متميزه مع السنغال كل رؤساء الامريكان
معظم رؤساء الامريكان زاروا
السنغال كلينتون بوش الابن بوش الاب
اوباما كندي فهناك علاقات تاريخه لكن
ما الاتفاقيه التي وقعتموها لوجود امريكي
في اي في اي وقت كان
للولايات المتحده علاقه قديمه مع السنغال
على الرغم من اختلاف اللغه
فالتعاون بيننا حيوي للغايه على المستويين
الاقتصادي والتجاري
اسلافي كل عمل مع نظيره الامريكي في وقته
عملت انا في البدايه مع الرئيس اوباما ثم
مع الرئيس ترامب وحاليا مع الرئيس بايدن
وقمنا من خلال ادارتينا بتعزيز هذا
التعاون من خلال اليات تعاون متنوعه على
سبيل المثال كانت مؤسسه تحدي الالفيه احد
ركائز هذا التعاون وكذلك كانت الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه وهيئه السلام
وغيرها تربطنا ايضا اتفاقيات وسياسات
مشتركه فيما يتعلق بالتعاون العسكري وهذا
طبيعي جدا ولكن علاقاتنا مع فرنسا هي
الاقدم اعتقد ان السنغال ليس لها عدو
ليس لديها منطقه حمراء ازور موسكو كما
ازور بكين او باريس او واشنطن ليست لدي
هذه المشكله لانني اعتبر انه لا مشكله
بيننا وبين اي بلد بعينه وما يحكم
العلاقات هو المصلحه المتبادله اذا وجدت
مصلحه مشتركه نقوم بتطوير تلك العلاقات
السيد الرئيس من الامتياز الذي منحتمونه
الولايات المتحده الامتياز العسكري الذي
منحتمونه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
الاتفاقيه الاخيره
ليس هناك اي امتياز اعتقد ان تعاوننا مع
الولايات المتحده لا يمكن قياسه بمنطق
الامتيازات ليس لدينا اي اتفاقيات عسكريه
خاصه مع الولايات المتحده ليس لديها قواعد
عسكريه عندنا ولكننا نتقاسم معلومات
استخباراتيه من خلال اجهزتنا في مجال
مكافحه الارهاب ولكن اولا وقبل كل شيء
نتشارك قيم الديمقراطيه وحقوق ولكن مع
احترام حدودنا في مجال حقوق الانسان لان
هناك نقاطا نختلف معهم حولها تماما وعليه
نحن نقوم باي شيء يسمح لنا بالتعاون معهم
بشكل فعال مثل ما نفعل مع الشركاء الاخرين
مثل الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين وغيرهما في
الحقيقه لا توجد اي خصوصيه محدده للتعاون
مع الولايات المتحده لكن علاقاتها مع
السنغال جيده جدا هل يبدو ان الولايات
المتحده في صراع مع اللاعبين الدوليين
الاخرين مع الفرنسيين على وجه التحديد لم
يكن لديها موقف مبدئي من انقلابات وهي
دوله الديمقراطيه راعي الديمقراطيه في
العالم كما تقول لم يكن لديها موقف مبدئي
من انقلابات التي الحاصله
الولايات المتحده موقفا ربما اللهجه
المستخدمه لم تكن هي نفسها ولكن راينا منذ
البدايه ان الولايات المتحده ادانت
الانقلاب نعم لم تستخدم الكلمه على الفور
لكن دانه الاستيلاء على السلطه وحبس
الرئيس وطالبت باستعاده النظام الدستوري
ويمكن فهم هذا الموقف لاسباب داخليه في
الولايات المتحده اعتقد ان التوصيف اللغوي
اختلف اعتمادا على حقائق معينه والمصلحه
الوطنيه الخاصه في تلك اللحظه ولكن من حيث
المبدا نحن في توافق تام معها هل تمت يعني
الصراع امريكي فرنسي امريكي اوروبي في
افريقيا
لا لست على علم بصراع مماثل على الاطلاق
ولا اعتقد وجوده ايضا الامريكيون
والفرنسيون والامريكيون والاوروبيون كلهم
في الكتله نفسها ربما تكون هناك اختلافات
صغيره لكنني اعتقد اساسا انهم ينتمون الى
نفس الكتله الغربيه وقد تكون هناك مقاربات
مختلفه حول موضوع بعينه فلا اعتقد وجود اي
خلافات عميقه بين هذين البلدين هذا ياخذنا
ايضا للحليف الروسي او اللاعب ايضا اكثر
اهميه للاعب الصاعد الان في افريقيا روسيا
في القمه الاخيره النسخه الثانيه اعلن عن
التعاون كبير بين الدول الافريقيه طبعا
انا افهم انه هذا من صالح افريقيا ان يكون
لديها شركاء كثر سواء امريكا فرنسا
الاوروبيين الصينيين الروس الاتراك في
روسيا مع روسيا تحديدا الموقف معقد لانه
روسيا في حاله عيدان مع الغرب وفي حرب
اوكرانيا بدات توضع عقبات كثيره الا
تمنعكم علاقاتكم الفرنسيه الامريكيه من
التقدم في العلاقات مع روسيا
روسيا دوله كبرى دخلت في صراع مع الغرب
منذ الحرب الاخيره في اوكرانيا وحتى قبلها
بامد بعيد فلا ينبغي ان نظن ان هذا الخلاف
الروسي الغربي يعود الى وقت الحاضر واذا
كان الامر قد تفاقم منذ غزو اوكرانيا فهذه
هي العلاقات بين روسيا والغرب نحن افريقيا
لسنا روسيا ولا الغرب لذلك يجب الا ننحاز
الى معسكر او اخر ولكننا حاولنا في هذه
الازمه اولا ان نحترم مبادئ الامم المتحده
اي احترام الحدود الدوليه هذا ما قلناه
مرارا وتكرارا وفي كل مكان يجب احترام
الحدود الدوليه وفقا لمبادئ ميثاق الامم
المتحده ثم قلنا نحن الافارقه متاثرون
بهذه الحرب لاننا للاسف نستورد الكثير من
القمح من روسيا واوكرانيا كما نستورد
الكثير من الاسمده الزراعيه وبالتالي
فالحرب تقوض نظام نا الزراعيه وامنن
الغذائي لذلك بالنسبه لنا حتى لو استمرت
الحرب يجب ان نعمل حتى لا تطال العقوبات
قطاع التغذيه لقد حاولنا في هذا الصدد حتى
قبل التوصل الى الاتفاق بشان الحبوب
ذهبت بنفسي الى سوتشي باسم الاتحاد
الافريقي لاقول للرئيس بوتين اننا بحاجه
الى وجود تسهيلات لتمرير الصادرات عن طريق
البحر الاسود
كما نحتاج ايضا نحن الافارقه الى شراء
الحبوب الروسيه والاسمده
كما ابلغنا شركائنا الغربيين بذلك حتى لا
تشمل العقوبات هذا المجال وفعلا استجابوا
لمطلبنا الا ان انظمه الدفع واجهت بعض
الصعوبات ولكن في النهايه نحن نسعى الى
الدفاع عن انفسنا والناي بانفسنا عن
المشكلات كما ندعو الى السلام في هذا
الصراع الروسي الاوكراني نحن نعلم ان
الامر ليس سهلا ولكننا نواصل اسماع صوتنا
من اجل وقف التصعيد وفي هذا الاطار تندرج
المبادره الافريقيه التي دعت الطرفين
لاعطاء الاولويه للحوار وللحلول الانسانيه
حتى نتمكن من التوصل للاتفاق
ماذا لدى روسيا لتقدمه بشكل مفيد ومميز
لافريقيا غير فاقناريان
هذا سؤال جيد العلاقات بين السنغال وروسيا
هي علاقات تجاريه لدينا تجاره في مجال
المحصبات وفي مجال الحبوب تماما كما هو
الحال مع اوكرانيا ولدينا ايضا مع البلدين
مشتريات اخرى تتمثل في المعدات العسكريه
طائرات هليكوبتر من الجانب الروسي
ومدفعيات من الجانب الاوكراني هذا في اطار
التجاره الدوليه لكن ليست بيننا اي علاقه
خاصه اخرى اللهم الا اذا كان تعاوننا في
قطاع صيد الاسماك
الصين ايضا تطورت علاقاتها مع افريقيا من
100 مليار ريوان الى 1880 مليار يوان معدل
نمو سنوي 17% من 2000 الى 2023
اكثر الوجوه الغريبه نراها هنا اوروبيه
وصينيه حتى في الطائره يبدو الصينيين يعني
لديهم الكثير
ليفعلوه في افريقيا
نعم لدينا علاقات ممتازه مع الصين قائمه
على الاحترام المتبادل لاولوياتنا المبنيه
على سهوله الاجراءات فيما يتعلق بتمويل
التنميه فنحن نحاول جذب انتباه شركائنا
جميعا بما في ذلك الشركاء المتعدد
والاطراف لاننا نعاني بشكل كبير من
اجراءات الشركاء والمانحين لاغراض
الشفافيه في بعض الاحيان ويمكننا ان نتفهم
ذلك ولكن اذا كنا دوله ديمقراطيه تدري
انتخابات في فترات زمنيه محدده وولايات
الرئاسيه محدوده فلا يمكننا ان نبقي على
الاجراءات المطوله التي قد تتداخل مع هذه
الفترات
فقد ننتخب رئيسا لكنه لن يلبث ان ينجز
شيئا حتى يتم تغييره بعد خمس سنوات من
انتخابه فتكون هناك في كل مره بدايه من
نقطه الصفر اما مع الصينيين بمجرد الاتفاق
على المشروع بشكل عام يمكن ان تتسارع
الوتيره ولكن منذ انتشار جائحه كورونا اقر
بان الامور تباطات بعض الشيء لكنك اذا
حاولت اجراء تقييم شامل على مدى السنوات
العشر الماضيه فان المبالغ التي تمكنت من
الافراج عنها مع الصين هي الاكبر على
الاطلاق على المستوى الثنائي بالمقارنه مع
شركاء الاخرين هذه المبالغ تناهز مليارين
و500 مليون دولار في مجال البنيه التحتيه
فقط كالطرق السريعه وغيرها لدينا تعاون مع
كل دوله من الدول الاخرى بعضها على شكله
بات مثل الامريكيين من خلال مؤسسه التحدي
الالفيه ومع الاتحاد الاوروبي
وعلى الرغم من اهميه الهبات فان المبالغ
التي تصل منها لا تسمح بتلبيه احتياجاتنا
لان الاحتياجات هائله فالقاره شابه
وسكانها بحاجه الى الخدمات الاجتماعيه
الاساسيه
كالمستفيات والطرق والكهرباء وغيرها ولهذا
فالاحتياجات الافريقيه كبيره للغايه ويمكن
لجميع الشركاء في الواقع ان يجدوا له
مكانا في القاره وبالعوده الى حاله الصين
فالافارقه بشكل عام لديهم تعاون ايجابي مع
الصين السيد الرئيس انه من الجيد ان يكون
لديك عدد كبير من الشركاء هذا امر مهم لكل
الدول من الشريك المفضل او الاول
شركه اقتصادي اكبر من بين هؤلاء اللاعبين
خاصه وايضا تركيا دخلت على الخط ولديها
استثمار في افريقيا ولديها حتى رحلات
طيران للسنغال الوحيده لديها رحلات مباشره
يوميه من الشركه المفضل والاكثر اهميه
للسنغال فرنسا
اذا كان علي ان اذكر الشريك الذي تربطنا
به اوثق العلاقات اقتصاديا فهو فرنسا
لانها وعلى العكس مما يبدو تظل بفضل
شركاتها الموجوده هنا وحجم التجاره بيننا
الشركه التجاري الاول للسنغال وكذلك
الاتحاد الاوروبي اذا قمت باجراء حساب
سريع تتبعهم الصين مباشره وبعدها تاتي
تركيا ولكن لدينا ايضا تعاون مع دول
الخليج وهو تعاون يتم بشكل اساسي من خلال
البنك الاسلامي للتنميه الذي يتدخل بشكل
كبير في السنغال في مشاريع هيكليه كبرى
مثل القطار الاقليمي السريع الذي شارك في
تمويله مع فرنسا الى جانب البنك الافريقي
للتنميه هؤلاء هم الشركاء الثلاثه البنك
الدولي ايضا شارك في تمويل مشروع الحافلات
سريعه التردد وهي مشاريع صديقه
ومشاريع للنقل الجماعي مره اخرى من الصعب
عليه ان اقول ان بلدا بعينه اهم من الاخر
بالنسبه لنا لكن اذا كان علينا التصنيف
بحسب حجم الاستثمارات والتجاره فبطبيعه
الحال تظل فرنسا في المقدمه ثم الصين
وبعدهما جميع الدول الاخرى التي تتعامل مع
السنغال
سيد الرئيس اود ان اشكرك على وجودك معنا
في الجزء الاول من المقابله
شكرا جزيلا الشكر موصول لكم وانتم
مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب المتابعه هذه
الحلقه خصصنا عن افريقيا عن الحاله
السياسيه والتنمويه والشراكات ايضا
الدوليه للقاره مع الرئيس كزعيم افريقي
كرئيس الاتحاد السابق الاتحاد الافريقي
ايضا عضو الاكواس وكل الاشكاليات المتعلقه
بافريقيا والمحيط الدولي بشكل عام الحلقه
القادمه سنخصصها للسنغال للرئيس ماكس الذي
ينهي ولايته الثانيه هذه الاشهر
ويتوقف عن الترشح بشكل استثنائي لا يحدث
كثيرا في افريقيا ولا في عالمنا العربي عن
التنميه الاقتصاديه الاستثنائيه التي
شهدتها السنغال في عهد الرئيس ملكي سالفه
العشر سنوات الاخيره وعن النهضه وعن
الاستقرار في هذه البلاد شكرا لكم على طيب
المتابعه المقبل في امان الله
[موسيقى]